bonsoir et bienvenue sur LCP ravi de
vous retrouver l'actualité ce soir c'est
longue de choc du
Qatar gate jusqu'où va s'étendre ce
scandale de corruption au parlement
européen évacelli la principale mise en
cause arrêtée ce week-end n'est plus
vice-présidente ce soir ça fonctionne
lui a été retirée mais au-delà quelles
conséquence pour l'institution
européenne pression lobby transparence
faut-il changer les règles nos
démocraties sont-elles à ce point
vulnérables grand débat dans un instinct
avec nos invités sur ce plateau notre
grand témoin ce soir est une grande
historienne son livre l'air du témoin
est une référence un tournant même dans
l'histoire de la Shoah et des Juifs du
20e siècle pour la première fois et bien
c'est elle le témoin de sa propre
histoire familiale qu'elle raconte dans
tombeau au pluriel publié au Seuil prix
Femina essai Annette viviorka sera avec
nous dans la deuxième partie enfin nos
affranchis ce soir Marco pommier a
récolté les pronos des députés sur la
demi-finale France Maroc de demain et
puis les polémiques souvent stériles qui
entoure ce match les prix de Vincent
Hugel sur la conférence de Paris pour
l'Ukraine ne pas oublier qu'avant
l'après-guerre il y a là la guerre et
oui et puis le parti pris de la
féministe les à chamboncelle sur le
bilan de la parité en politique à
rapport était remis hier à la première
ministre voilà vous savez tout pour le
menu c'est vert c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est sans doute le plus gros scandale
de corruption au parlement européen et
les révélations ne font manifestement
que commencer bonsoir Nathalie Loiseau
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes députés européenne du groupe
réunion ou dans lequel siège les
macronistes ancienne ministre chargés
des relations européennes et vous venez
de publier la guerre qu'on ne voit pas
venir aux éditions de l'Observatoire
cyber attack vrai troll faux médias et
dire que vous croyez vivre en paix voilà
pour le sous-titre c'est évidemment et
malheureusement parfaitement d'actualité
bonsoir Richard Verly bonsoir visage
familier évidemment de cette émission
vous êtes le correspondant France Europe
pour le média Suisse Blic et vous
connaissez par cœur les arcanes de la
vie politique à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg bonsoir anne-charlaine Bedina
bonsoir et merci d'être la
constitutionnaliste maître de conférence
en droit public à Sciences Po Paris et à
l'Université de Rouen on a besoin de vos
lumières pour comprendre les règles qui
encadrent les lobbys et la transparence
en Europe et puis bonsoir Manon merci
d'être à distance depuis le Parlement de
Strasbourg où se tenait une session
plénière on vous a beaucoup entendu sur
ce scandale on a beaucoup de questions à
vous poser mais d'abord retour sur les
faits et les réactions avec vous
Stéphane si j'ai bien compris le
catargate est en 3 minutes le billet de
Blacko tout de suite
[Musique]
Stéphane bonsoir à toutes salut Richard
si j'ai bien compris ce soir alors si
j'ai bien compris Myriam sur les 705
députés européens du Parlement de
Strasbourg depuis samedi il y en a une
qui dort en prison à Bruxelles la chute
est évidemment rude pour elle d'autant
que son ascension a été fulgurante elle
s'appelle Eva Kylie a 26 ans elle était
présentatrice du JT à la télévision
grecque vous voyez que ça peut mener à
tout ensuite elle a été élu députée grec
puis député européenne en 2014 donc ça
fait 8 ans qu'elle est au Parlement
européen et donc ces ancienneté elle
avait même été nommée au poste de
vice-présidente il y en a 14 mais elle a
obtenu un de ses postes au Parlement et
elle n'était pas protégée par son
immunité parlementaire et non parce que
l'immunité ça ne marche pas quand on est
pris en flagrant délice qui est son cas
puisque les policiers ont trouvé des
sommes d'argent qui très importantes
lorsqu'ils ont mené des perquisitions
chez elle et ses complices donc d'où
vient l'argent mais tout le monde
regarde le Qatar qui aurait donc payé et
va Kylie pour
défendre le petit émirat au sein du
Parlement européen c'est vrai quand on
écoute ces discours à propos du Qatar
bon elle en parle carrément comme un des
champions du droit du travail on écoute
j'ai été la seule à dire que le Qatar
est un leader en matière de droit du
travail c'était le Somfy pourtant
certains ici appellent à les discriminer
il les intimides et accuse de corruption
offre
chez vous c'est un peu embarrassant
alors comment a réagi l'Union européenne
on va dire ça aussi l'entre colère et
puis inquiétude aussi on parle de
l'inquiétude en premier la première
réagir c'était
Ursula vanderleyen qui s'inquiétait tout
simplement c'est la présidente de la
commission je le rappelle pour ceux qui
sont pas très européens
en effet les allégations contre la
vice-présidente du Parlement européen
sont très sérieuses et nous savons
qu'elle soulève de sérieuses
préoccupations car il s'agit de la perte
de confiance des gens dont nos
institutions européennes
donc évidemment un risque que scandale
porte produit à l'image de toute l'Union
européenne en définitive et ça c'est un
petit peu dommage parce que regardez
depuis la crise du covid notamment en
France l'image de l'Union européenne au
contraire est en train de s'améliorer
sur les trois dernières années donc ce
serait quand même dommage qu'un moche
qu'un vilain scandale de corruption
vienne ruiner cette cette amélioration
d'image également alors évidemment
d'abord de la colère contre Eva Kylie
avec le vote des députés ce matin qui a
exprimé ça les présidents de par le
Marocain on réunit les députés regardez
le résultat est-ce qu'il faut la priver
la suspendre de son rôle de
vice-présidente 6 de savoir pour deux
abstentions et une voix contre ce qui
s'est trompé de bouton pourquoi il a
voté contre
elle n'est plus vice-présidente mais ça
vise pas seulement elle la colère ça
vise aussi bien sûr les corrupteurs ceux
qui ont versé le pot de vin comme le
cathare n'est pas officiellement mis en
cause par les enquêteurs le nomme pas
précisément mais enfin Roberta mezzola
qui est la présidente du Parlement
européen quand elle en parlait ce matin
je pense que l'émir du Qatar avec des
oreilles qui sifflent en écoute
ne vous y trompez pas le Parlement
européen chers collègues est attaqué la
démocratie européenne est attaquée
et notre façon de créer des sociétés
démocratiques libres et ouvertes est
attaquée voilà une polémique de plus et
de taille pour le kata
améliorer leur image avec la Coupe du
monde je sais pas forcément gagner parce
que forcément ce scandale ça réveille
les partisans du boycott qui demande à
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que c'est
vraiment une bonne idée d'aller faire
des photos avec Kylian Mbappe tu peux
pas rester à l'Elysée pour voir le match
donc ça c'est ce que disait Yannick
Jadot sur RTL mais pour une fois on est
d'accord à la nupes puisque manuel
Bompard est sur la même ligne on
l'écoute vous savez l'équipe de France
elle a besoin du soutien de ses
supporters pour gagner elle a sans doute
pas besoin de la présence d'Emmanuel
Macron en tribune par contre les droits
de l'homme au Qatar eux ils ont besoin
de l'action diplomatique de la France
alors est-ce que le président doit on ne
peut pas ne doit pas aller supporter les
Bleus vous allez en parler certainement
poser la question
George malbruno donc qui s'est fait
notamment connaître par deux bouquins
qu'il a publié sur le Qatar 2014-2019
sur l’influence occulte du Qatar en
France aussi bien dans le domaine
économique dans le domaine de la
progression de l'islam radical donc il
était il est un peu le spécialiste de
l'influence du Qatar et ce matin quand
tu lui as demandé de commentaires
scandale actuelle voilà ce qu'il a dit
et ce qui est rare quand même c'est de
se faire prendre parce que c'est une
pratique qui est assez courante qui est
ancienne cette capacité d'acheter de
l'influence mais en général les circuits
sont assez bien rodés et ce qui est très
difficile c'est d'établir justement la
preuve de la corruption même simplement
l'effet donc vous voyez son étonnement
c'est quand même ça c'est quand même
bizarre d'avoir un si gros sac d'argent
liquide que sous son oreiller dit-il et
puis surtout il suggère que ce n'est que
la partie émergée d'un iceberg ou elle
s'est fait prendre parce que elle est
complètement naïve ou les autres en
revanche sont beaucoup plus discrets et
cela
va-t-il aller merci beaucoup merci pour
ce point factuel complet je vous propose
tout de suite d'aller à Bruxelles parce
que Manon brille nous attend sur place
je sais que vous êtes pressé ma nombril
merci de nous accorder
cette visioconférence depuis votre
bureau euros à Strasbourg pardonnez-moi
alors moi ce qui me frappe depuis ce
weekend on parle de scandale historique
de corruption mais c'est qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup de
députés qui redoutaient ce scénario qui
ne sont pas vraiment surpris je crois
que c'est votre cas Manon Aubry
êtes-vous choqué oui mais véritablement
surprise par l'ampleur de ce scandale ce
soir
vous avez bien résumé les choses je suis
évidemment choquée par l'ampleur du
scandale c'est sans doute le plus gros
scandale de l'histoire du Parlement
européen mais je dois dire aussi que je
ne suis pas véritablement surprise pour
avoir travaillé de longues dates sur les
violations des droits de l'homme au
Qatar j'ai bataillé pendant plus d'un an
pour essayer d'obtenir une résolution au
Parlement européen condamnant fermement
les violations des droits humains
pendant un an j'ai essuyé le refus du
groupe socialiste et du groupe de la
droite et finalement au bout d'un an
avec l'ouverture de la Coupe du monde
j'ai réussi à l'obtenir alors à 16 voix
près à la dernière session plénière et
les négociations qui se sont déroulées
ensuite sont assez éclairantes y compris
au vu de ce que l'on sait maintenant de
ce scandale parce que ces deux groupes
là ont profité du huis clos des
négociations pour défendre à tout prix
le Qatar et clairement ils étaient là en
mission commandée pour protéger les
intérêts du Qatar pour s'assurer que le
texte ne soit le moins incisif possible
et je peux vous donner des exemples il
ne fallait pas mentionner les milliers
de victimes qui étaient morts sur les
chantiers de la Coupe du monde et il ne
fallait pas mentionner la responsabilité
directe du Qatar en matière de violation
des droits de l'homme mais par contre
pour citer la FIFA il y avait absolument
aucun problème et dernier exemple ils
ont voulu à tout prix ajouter dans ce
texte par exemple le fait que le Qatar
louait un rôle en matière énergétique ce
qui n'avait absolument aucun rapport
avec ce dont on achète le gaz
aujourd'hui faute de gaz russe Manon
brise que vous dites est très grave
parce qu'on a l'impression que le Qatar
a un filtré le Parlement européen vous
dites peut-être témoin de véritables
ingérence de ce pays sur les députés
pour influer la décision européenne
c'est très grave
quand je suis sortie de ces négociations
j'ai eu un sentiment que je n'ai jamais
eu dans d'autres négociations à tel
point qu'à ce moment-là je me j'ai fait
une vidéo où je me suis interrogée je
posais la question j'avais évidemment
c'était encore avec un point
d'interrogation où je me demandais si et
le
Qatar avait infiltré le Parlement
européen bon maintenant je crois que
depuis on peut lever le point
d'interrogation on a eu des éléments de
réponse ceci étant dit infiltré le
Parlement européen et utiliser tous les
moyens ne veut pas dire que l'ensemble
des députés européens sont corrompus
puisque malgré leur mobilisation nous
avait obtenu cette résolution j'aurais
souhaité qu'elle soit plus ambitieuse et
je comprends maintenant mieux les
réticences en particulier du groupe
socialiste mais je sais aussi qu'il
faudrait en tirer toutes les conclusions
pour que ce type de scandale ne soit pas
rendu possible il faudra à la fois une
commission d'enquête pour tirer au clair
les défaillances des institutions mais
aussi changer en profondeur de la cave
au grenier les règles éthiques au niveau
européen je
pour terminer ensuite on débat sur ce
plateau qu'est-ce que vous réclamez en
tant que député européenne ce soir
précisément
1 une commission d'enquête pour faire
toute la lumière sur les défaillances
des institutions européennes de le
renforcement des règles de transparence
pour rendre obligatoire le registre de
transparence et notamment obligé les
États tiers ce n'est pas le cas à
l'heure actuelle à s'inscrire dessus et
trois la création d'une autorité éthique
indépendante que nous demandons depuis
le début du mandat et que la Commission
européenne a mis sous le tapis je crois
que l'ampleur de ce scandale nous
rappelle l'urgence de cette autorité
éthique pour contrôler notamment les
éventuelles conflits d'intérêt et enfin
politiquement je crois qu'il faudra
assumer de faire le ménage au Parlement
européen si l'on veut représenter les
citoyens l'éthique plutôt que
malheureusement rendent des comptes web
gouvernés par le fric comme certains
députés merci beaucoup merci Aubry pour
votre intervention il y a beaucoup de
choses dans cette intervention mais on
va reprendre point par point Nathalie
Loiseau vous êtes aussi député
européenne choqué on l'imagine surprise
ou pas vraiment vous avez écrit ce livre
on aurait pu imaginer
des ingérences russes chinoises le Qatar
surprise mais il y en a dans ce livre
aussi je parle du Qatar
si j'ai écrit ce livre parce que je suis
inquiète pour nos démocraties je pense
aussi qu'elles ont tout en elle pour se
défendre à partir du moment où elles
ouvrent les yeux et j'espère qu'il va y
avoir avant le catarget et après le
catarget c'est à dire que à la fois les
menaces sont mieux mesurées et notre
capacité
démocratique à réagir sera mieux utilisé
parce que quand même encore faut-il
rebondir l'image figurez-vous
rendez-vous compte l'image du Parlement
donc elle me parle moi ce que je vous
dis la crédibilité la confiance ce que
je vous dis c'est deux choses d'une part
c'est que cette résolution qui montre du
doigt alcatar sur les droits de l'homme
sur les minorités sur les droits des
travailleurs elle a été votée très
largement
donc si c'est bien le Qatar et si il a
acheté une députée qu'elle a été
édulcorée c'est un échec
fait partie d'un groupe très minoritaire
au Parlement européen pour pas être
surpris que quand Manon Aubry rédige un
texte l'ensemble du Parlement européen
vote pas le texte de
qu'on a retrouvé je voudrais juste
terminer là-dessus 1 un texte a été voté
deux nous avons pris la décision de ne
pas voter cette semaine la
libéralisation des visas pour le Qatar
c'est vraiment l'arroseur au sens propre
arrosé si Qatar voulait améliorer son
image en réalité il a attiré l'attention
sur lui de la pire manière possible et
puis on est dans un état de droit madame
Kylie qui a tout simplement commis un
délit si on croit l'enquêteur s'agit pas
de comité d'éthique même si j'y suis
favorable mais madame Kylie aurait
jamais été demandé à un délontologue
s'il y avait le droit ou pas mettre des
sacs de d'argent sous son lit c'est pas
la bonne réponse madame Kylie
aujourd'hui elle dort en prison son
compagnon de en prison un juge belge a
fait un travail formidable il n'y a pas
eu effectivement d'immunité
parlementaire puisque le flagrant délit
avait été
constaté d'autres députés ont été
interrogés des assistants parlementaires
bref la règle de droit fait son travail
de manière exemplaire
du Parlement européen pour faire des
perquisitions heureusement qu'il y a
deux chevaliers blancs c'est pas vrai il
y a à l'évidence une personne peut-être
un groupe de personnes qui a commis
quelque chose à quoi je ne m'attendais
pas j'ai peur pour nos démocraties je
sais que des pays étrangers essayent de
les influencer je ne pouvais pas
imaginer que Madame Kylie on a touché de
l'argent la question c'est jusqu'où le
catargate Richard Verlet quand Roberta
metzola la présidente du Parlement
européen dit le Parlement est attaqué
que j'utilise le présent ça veut dire
qu'il est encore attaqué ça veut dire
que quoi précisément qui pourrait y
avoir d'autres redéputés qui tombent
avec ce scandale ce qui est certain
c'est que la question mérite d'être
posée si le Qatar puisqu'il s'agit de
cette émirats a réussi à acheter c'est
bien de ça dont on parle des députés il
est assez logique de se demander si
d'autres puissances beaucoup plus
influent beaucoup plus importante font
la même chose il me semble que dans
l'agenda d'aujourd'hui au Parlement
européen juste avant l'évocation du
Qatar il y avait l'interférence chinoise
sur les infrastructures européennes donc
la question que pose Roberta mezzallah
elle est absolument approprié juste
peut-être deux éléments d'abord acheter
des parlementaires dans l'histoire des
démocraties ça a toujours été ça a
toujours été le cas il y a toujours eu
cette tentation de la part de lobby ou
de puissance étrangère d'acheter des
parlementaires et lorsque les
démocraties européennes étaient encore
jeunes lorsqu'elles se formait il y
avait des parlementaires qui étaient
carrément achetés par des intérêts
privés donc il ne faut pas trop s'en
étonner là il y a deux choses moi qui
m'étonnent et que j'y crois il faut
retenir d'abord c'est qu'apparemment il
y avait un groupe bien identifié donc ça
veut dire quand même une forme de mafia
utilisons le mot au sein du Parlement
européen qui est vrai donc à édulcorer
les textes ou intervenir en faveur du
cataplaration
et des personnes qui ont été interpellés
problématique parce que ces gens qui
s'ils étaient à la solde d'une puissance
étrangère sont peut-être intervenus et
on va la perdre on va s'en apercevoir
bientôt sur d'autres dossiers une autre
manière et on ne connaît que quatre
personnes là il y a une question quand
même des fortifications de cette affaire
qui sont posées puis il y a une deuxième
question qui se pose c'est que moi je ne
crois pas du tout et là je rejoins un
homme oiseau dans la création d'un
comité d'éthique dans l'efficacité que
ce comité soit créé on peut le soutenir
mais qu'il puisse être efficace je crois
que la plus grande efficacité c'est
l'intervention tout simplement de la
justice et qu'elle est en main les
éléments
Qatar ce pays-là en particulier le fait
que ce soit lui qui soit aujourd'hui
soupçonné puisque on utilise encore du
conditionnel de corruption sur des élus
ça vous surprend il y a toutes les
polémiques autour du Mondial
influence que le Qatar a démarré il y a
maintenant au moment de l'attribution de
la Coupe du monde donc en 2010 si ma
mémoire est bonne une stratégie
d'influence évidemment alimentée par ce
que le cadavre ce dont dispose le Qatar
c'est à dire de l'argent du cash ils en
ont beaucoup je rappelle quand même
qu'il y avait quelqu'un avant Libye qui
s'applique Kadhafi qui a fait ça pendant
des années il a eu exactement la même
stratégie c'est-à-dire d'arroser tout le
monde de dollars est-ce que Bruno
spécialiste au Figaro de ce pays dit que
pendant très longtemps c'était pratique
courante parce que même le cathare a
arrêté parce que les élus étaient trop
gourmands alors il y a peut-être ça il y
a le fait que le Qatar paradoxalement
paradoxalement le Qatar aujourd'hui
c'est assez étonnant que cette affaire
sorte en pleine cour du monde parce que
le moment où le Qatar a sans doute tarie
la manne c'est récemment parce que ils
veulent devenir respectable je crois
qu'il y a des états vous savez chaque
État intervient avec ce qu'il a chaque
État disons démocratique intervient avec
ce dont il dispose dans le cas des pays
du Golfe c'est l'argent c'est l'argent
cash donc en retrouver malheureusement
chez certains députés ça n'est en soi
pas très étonnant reconnaît son le alors
un instant encore sur les effets l'onde
de choc jusqu'où puis on parle des
règles juste après regardez ce tweet de
Victor Orban bonjour au Parlement
ironistique photo et légendes à l'appui
et là dit la photo ils ont dit qu'ils
étaient vivement préoccupés par la
corruption en Hongrie je rappelle que la
Hongrie est menacée de ne plus recevoir
les fonds européens pour des questions
justement de corruption et puis regardez
ce qu'elle dit Jordan Bardella cet
après-midi
c'est bien placé la religion des droits
de l'homme s'arrête donc là où commence
les valises de billets alors que l'Union
européenne s'est érigée en modèle de
vertus en donneuse de leçons en juge
moralisateur de tous les régimes du
monde la voici présumée corrompue à son
plus haut niveau par l'argent d'un État
islamique
ce scandale démocratique qui frappe
aujourd'hui le Parlement européen dans
l'une des vice-présidentes vient d'être
écrouée à le mérite de mettre fin à une
mascarade la mascarade de ceux qui
portent en bandoulière les valeurs de
l'Europe la mascarade de ceux qui
hurlent le plus fort dans la défense de
la démocratie la mascarade des
socialistes soupçonnés ici au Parlement
européen d'avoir touché de l'argent du
Qatar
c'est du pain béni pour tous les
eurosceptiques on a vu Orban on voit le
rassemblement national cette onde de
choc jusqu'au peut-elle aller il y a le
mélange de beaucoup de choses en fait
dans cette affaire qui est rocambolesque
qui a tout du feuilleton on retrouve un
état puissant étrangère qui influence la
démocratie directement on retrouve des
sommes obscures on est à nouveau dans le
soupçon néanmoins il faut quand même pas
à mon avis tout mélanger la question de
savoir si l'Union européenne est
légitime à imposer des sanctions elle ne
se pose évidemment pas elle fait partie
de ses chefs de compétences les valeurs
de l'État droit sont rappelées dans les
traités fondateurs donc on est loin
d'être dans une revendication de probité
de la part de l'Union européenne pour
acquérir un titre qu'elle n'a pas donc
il faut il faut rappeler quand même les
règles telles qu'elles existent
néanmoins ce que ça pourrait
mentalisation
et vous parliez tout à l'heure du
sentiment de confiance et
malheureusement en politique et en
démocratie on ne peut pas travailler
qu'avec des règles de droit il y a aussi
de l'ordre voilà du sentiment d'adhésion
qui doit se créer et les institutions
européennes peut-être par rapport à leur
jeunesse par rapport aux démocraties
européennes ont toujours pati d'un
défaut de légitimité de confiance de
reconnaissance parfois par les
populations intérieures des démocraties
néanmoins je crois qu'il faut pas tout
mélanger non plus dans dans le niveau de
responsabilité on parle aussi beaucoup
de renforcer l'éthique auprès du
Parlement européen soit néanmoins il ne
faut pas confondre lobbying et
corruption le lobbying c'est le fait
voilà de vouloir influencer un processus
décisionnel ici on est vraiment dans des
valises de billets donc on est dans
quelque chose de totalement pénal dit
légal qui pourrait être reprochés
indépendamment même du Cénacle
parlementaire c'est du droit pénal c'est
de la répression d'une action
frauduleuse voilà il faut il faut le
redire vous ne croyez pas une sorte de
portée symbolique lourde sur l'adhésion
aux institutions et à l'Europe en
général j'en veux à ceux qui salissent
l'image des institutions évidemment mais
je crois aussi à la capacité de ces
institutions à réagir et je mettrai en
garde aussi bien Victor urban que Jordan
Bardella Victor urban d'abord parce que
il y a un consensus maintenant au niveau
de l'Union européenne pour geler des
fonds à destination de la Hongrie cette
affaire ce serait passé en Hongrie y
aurait-il eu quelqu'un d'arrêter il y
aurait-il eu une procédure judiciaire
indépendante évidemment non et quand je
vois monsieur Bardella et Madame Le Pen
se précipitait sur ce sujet comme s'ils
avaient un immense ouf de soulagement
comme s'il se disait pour une fois c'est
pas nous qu'on regarde je suis désolé
mais quand les démocraties sont
attaquées elles le sont par plusieurs
pays et à plusieurs moyens dans le livre
que j'ai publié je rappelle les emprunts
de Madame Le Pen et du rassemblement
national non remboursé auprès d'une
entreprise russe qui fait du trafic
d'armes avec la série de Bachar el-Assad
je rappelle que le rassemblement
national que Madame Le Pen est mis en
examen pour détournement de fonds
publics c'est le rassemblement national
qui va piloter une commission d'enquête
sur la gérance de puissance j'espère
qu'il viendront me proposer d'être
auditionné parce que j'aurais des choses
à dire si on croit vraiment à la
démocratie si on a peur qu'elle soit
attaquée on la défend contre tous ceux
qui lui veulent du mal à commencer par
les pays étrangers comme la Russie je
rappelle que encore il y a deux semaines
monsieur Bardella voté contre le fait
que la Russie puisse être un état
soutien du terrorisme alors très bien
c'est très clair sur les faits
maintenant on va voir s'il y a des
règles à changer ou si avec l'Arsenal
tout le temps en Europe ce scandale
n'aurait pas pu être évité depuis ce
week-end c'est l'arsenal législatif
français pour lutter contre les conflits
d'intérêt et la pression des lobbys qui
est cité en exemple alors nos règles en
matière de transparence peuvent-elles
servir de modèle avant de vous entendre
et demander réponse avec Baptiste Gary
Chartier
c'est l'affaire qui a tout déclenché en
2012 scandale au gouvernement lorsque
Jérôme Cahuzac garant et compte public
tenter d'échapper au fisc depuis la
France est dotée d'outils alors quels
sont les parades mises en place contre
la corruption
dans la foulée de cette affaire n'est
sans 2013 de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
l'objectif contrôler les intérêts et le
patrimoine des élus dont les ministres
et les députés
l'exécutif consulte cet instant pour
évaluer les ministres mais lorsqu'il y a
fraude exit du gouvernement illustration
le mois dernier avec Caroline Cayeux
l'ex-ministre des collectivités
territoriales étaient soupçonnées
d'avoir menti dans sa déclaration de
patrimoine mais faut-il aller plus loin
en 2017 Michel Sapin ministre du Budget
formule une étape supplémentaire avec sa
loi pour la transparence clarification
donc d'une relation d'intérêt entre les
lobbys et les responsables politiques
pour servir l'intérêt des Français il y
ait plus de transparence qu'il y ait
plus de justice à la fois dans les
relations économiques et dans les
relations sociales et dans les relations
financières
mais ces outils sont-ils suffisants
certains députés mettent en garde et
formules des propositions pour un
lobbing plus responsable comme le rendu
public des agendas parlementaires en
2019 déjà certains députés y étaient
favorables je pense qu'on a rien à
cacher et rien à craindre à faire ce
travail de transparence c'est pratique
de lobbying soit beaucoup plus
sévèrement encadré qu'aujourd'hui c'est
aussi pour ça que je propose que tous
les parlementaires soient obligés de
publier la liste de leurs rendez-vous
avec les lobbys les signes de défiance
vis-à-vis de la classe politique reste
nombreux selon une dernière étude 30%
des sondées se disent méfiants à l'égard
de leurs institutions
on va rentrer dans le détail parce que
comme vous l'avez déjà dit entre la
question des lobbies et un acte de
corruption pure et dur c'est de choses
bien différentes est-ce que vous pensez
qu'avec les règles françaises à la fois
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique et l'encadrement du
pouvoir des lobbies un scandale comme
celui de Bruxelles aurait été quand même
possible alors oui et non c'est à dire
que la législation française c'est
beaucoup améliorée depuis les récences
scandales qu'à usach la loi de
moralisation l'affaire Fillon et donc on
peut espérer parfois que les scandales
amènent à des sursauts de législation
donc ça pourrait être le cas au
Parlement européen oui et non pourquoi
parce que notre législation est certes
complète mais encore une fois on est
dans le cadre ici d'un délit pénal et
donc on peut pas vraiment on l'a déjà
dit d'ailleurs et vous l'avez dit on
avait longtemps en France le délit de
haut trahison d'ailleurs pour pour nos
députés pour nous pour nos élus quand
ils avaient tendance à aller vendre des
informations puissances étrangères donc
ça c'est ça c'est quelque chose qui de
toute façon est pénalisé dans toutes les
démocraties néanmoins
pas c'est vrai qu'il faut le dire c'est
une institution indépendante de contrôle
au-dessus de lui des règles qu'il
s'appliquent néanmoins on peut pas dire
que l'Union européenne soit dépourvue de
règles de transparence sur la question
des lobbies bien au contraire parce
qu'en réalité le Parlement européen est
bien plus fréquemment on va dire
contacter et
présents
dans la culture française on pourrait
plus faire le parallèle avec les
États-Unis dans ce cadre là et la
législation européenne c'est celle du
registre c'est à dire que on déclare on
a donc cette obligation de déclarer ses
rendez-vous sauf que pour le Parlement
européen ça n'est pas d'application
obligatoire générale et pour tous les
députés c'est seulement les présidents
de commission ou à certains égards
certains rapporteurs donc on pourrait
généraliser cette règle on pourrait
renforcer le contrôle avec une autorité
indépendante il faut savoir que la Cour
Européenne des comptes n'a pas de
mission particulière là-dessus donc en
effet il manque un arsenal
des comptes pourraient jouer le rôle de
la Haute Autorité en Europe et on
devrait demander ça n'est pas garanti
néanmoins je pense que en tout cas le
vœu qui est appelé de la part de des
députés c'est de de copier un petit peu
ce modèle français avec une autorité
indépendante au dessus du Parlement
puisqu'on a toujours cette question en
démocratie qu'on s'est tous posé à un
moment ou un autre de notre histoire qui
contrôle les gardiens qui gardera nos
gardiens qui contrôlent les députés
européens en matière de transparence
d'éthique de conflits potentiels
Nathalie Loiseau moi je suis très
favorable à ce qu'on ait une haute
autorité de la transparence de la vie
publique européenne pour toutes les
institutions européennes Parlement
commission mais aujourd'hui ça se passe
comment vous avez une déclaration
d'intérêts et de montrer européenne
française et donc je l'ai rempli à la
chatvp en démarrant en mode autorité sur
la transpirer à la fin de mon mandat et
quand au milieu de votre mandat il vous
arrive quelque chose dans mon cas j'ai
perdu mon père j'ai hérité de mon père
j'ai fait une déco c'est la loi
française qui voulait impose même élu à
Bruxelles mais je souhaiter pas que tous
les élus européens et les fonctionnaires
de la Commission soient contraint à
faire la même chose je pense que ce
serait de bonnes administration une
manière de savoir s'il y a un
enrichissement indus ou non est-ce que
ça empêcherait des gens de
remettre des délits c'est très difficile
à dire je pense aussi que prendre
l'exemple des lobbys du Regis je
registre et des lobbies voilà moi j'ai
pris le parti non seulement de déclarer
systématiquement je préside une
commission au parlement européen il
m'arrive d'être rapporteur sur des
textes mais systématiquement je déclare
tous les représentants d'intérêt que je
rencontre et je vais même bien
comprendre pour ceux qui nous regardent
déclarer sur les agendas de façon
publique tous les rendez-vous permet
peut-être de soulever quelques
interrogations pour les journalistes qui
peuvent regarder ou d'autres attention
s'il y a trop de fois la même personne
le même le même groupe d'intérêt mon
agenda ça peut être et ça permet de
savoir qui j'ai vu et moi je dois
pouvoir justifier pourquoi je l'ai vu
les seuls que vous ne trouverez pas sur
mon agenda ce sont des militants des
droits de l'homme des dissidents des
opposants pour les protéger et encore il
m'arrive à l'heure demande de mettre le
rendez-vous publiquement pour les
protéger et je pense que ce que nombreux
nous sommes nombreux à faire ça sur une
base volontaire sur la base volontaire
c'est pas vrai tout simplement
obligatoire
il y a quand même des actions
symboliques qui pourraient être ou qui
devraient être prises maintenant je
trouve que par exemple les responsables
des trois institutions communautaires
c'est-à-dire le Conseil qui représente
les gouvernements la Commission et le
Parlement européen pourrait maintenant
décider d'avoir une action commune un
geste commun ça peut être soit une
commission commune par exemple confier
un mandat à la Cour des comptes
européennes bref là je pense que à ce
moment précis parler d'une seule voix
les trois photos qu'il y ait une parole
commune et une parole forte la deuxième
chose c'est que cette parole elle doit
aussi s'accompagner d'une vérité la
vérité c'est que vous n'empêcherez
jamais un député de toucher l'argent
d'une puissance étrangère s'il a envie
de le faire et s'il a envie d'être
acheté parce que la corruption
malheureusement elle est intrinsèque à
la vie des démocraties il faut
l'accepter il faut lutter contre mais il
faut pas être naïf non plus enfin une
troisième chose juste quand même je
voulais je voulais préciser il faut
aussi
que des députés qui ne sont pas payés
mais par conviction puisse dire par
exemple que le Qatar défend les
travailleurs donc il faut accepter que
des députés puissent avoir des positions
que l'on ne partage pas que l'on juge
aberrante c'est pas parce que un député
des trucs Qatar qu'il est nécessairement
payé par le Qatar alors anne-charlen
Bedina rapidement puis je voudrais vous
faire écouter un son c'est de rappeler
que la corruption est un acte individuel
alors que tout ce qu'on évoque par
rapport à la transparence et au lobbying
sont généralement des actions de groupe
et là en fait on est dans une petite
fenêtre de cette affaire c'est que il y
a cette corruption individuelle d'une
personne qui est mise en cause ici et
qui qui dort vous l'avez dit en prison
mais il y a aussi peut-être l'influence
de ce groupe parlementaire auquel elle
appartenait et qui avait l'air de
soutenir activement le Qatar donc en
fait la corruption elle est individuelle
après l'influence politique c'est sur ça
qu'on peut essayer un mot important
c'est le mot quand même qui a prononcé
genre là Jordan Bardella c'est le mot
d'islamisme parce que on va peut-être on
va peut-être trouver dans cette affaire
d'autres ramifications et vous aurez le
mot de la fin d'autres députés de droite
cette fois-ci comme François-Xavier
Bellamy soulève ce poids écoutez-le
le Qatar c'est en réalité le premier
financeur de l'islam politique dans
l'Union européenne aujourd'hui et cette
affaire jette une lumière très
particulière sur les derniers événements
que nous avons connus souvenez-vous je
vous en avais déjà parlé lorsque nous
avons tenté lorsque nous avons réussi à
par un amendement empêcher la Commission
européenne de continuer de financer des
campagnes de publicité qui expliquent
par exemple que la joie est dans le
hijab les institutions européennes sont
aujourd'hui ciblées par un entrisme
déterminé de l'islam politique et le
Qatar en est en réalité je le redis le
premier organisateur
Nathalie Loiseau il a raison de soulever
cette dimension politique de l'agenda du
Qatar il a raison et je le remercie de
salut l'amendement que j'avais réussi à
faire à faire voter bien sûr et
l'ingérence ça passe aussi par des
associations religieuses le Qatar auprès
des islamistes mais les évangélistes
chrétiens américains étaient il y a un
mois au Parlement européen à la vitesse
de l'extrême droite pour une conférence
contre l'avortement c'est tout ça que je
dénonce dans mon livre c'est là-dessus
que on doit réagir l'exposé le faire
connaître il y a une commission spéciale
au Parlement européen qui traite des
ingérences j'ai un seul regret c'est que
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche
nous disent il faut que cette commission
s'arrête non il faut de cette commission
devienne une commission d'enquête on
verra quelles seront les décisions
bien sûr les Européens par l'Union
européenne les 27 le Parlement la
commission également comment faire en
sorte que ça n'arrive plus merci à vous
merci d'être venu sur le plateau LCP
pour ce débat on va accueillir à présent
notre grand témoin c'est une grande
historienne et son livre l'air du témoin
est une référence était même un tournant
dans l'histoire à la fois de la Shoah et
des Juifs au 20e siècle alors pour la
première fois et bien c'est elle le
témoin de sa propre histoire familiale
qu'elle raconte dans ton beau au pluriel
publié au Seuil et prix féminin et c'est
à Nadia nous rejoint juste après
l'invitation signé ce soir par Marco
pommier
si on vous invite à net viviorka c'est
pour parler des vôtres du parcours de
votre famille juive polonaise décimée
par la Seconde Guerre mondiale 3 de vos
grands-parents sans compter des oncles
des tentes et des cousins seront
déportés puis exterminés la Shoah vous
échappera toujours dites-vous ça reste
pour moi inouï c'est à dire que ça reste
incompréhensible comment
est-ce possible que l'on veuille
assassiner sans raison ce n'est donc pas
par hasard à netviorca que vous êtes
devenu historienne spécialiste
mondialement reconnus de la Shoah
plusieurs dizaines d'années de recherche
une mission d'études sur la spoliation
des biens juifs et des livres marquants
comme l'air du témoin ou quand le témoin
devient un porteur d'histoire et de
mémoire aujourd'hui vous publiez
l'autobiographie de votre famille des
années 20 jusqu'à l'après-guerre tombeau
au pluriel comme autant de vie
singulière que vous relatez avec
précision à travers des archives des
témoignages et des souvenirs c'est aussi
quelque chose que j'ai fait pour moi
c'est à ce livre n'est pas sorti de ma
tête d'un coup j'y ai pensé pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années et j'ai mis
quelques années à l'écrire aussi un
hommage à ceux qui ne sont pas revenus
rendre vivant vos grands-parents arrêtés
puis déportés par le convoi 61 entre
Drancy et à Auschwitz ce camp où les
deux sœurs de votre père connaîtront le
même sort rendre vivant aussi cette
grand-mère maternelle noyée dans la zone
alors qu'elle tentait de franchir la
ligne de démarcation je voulais rendre
sensible l'histoire et pour la rendre
sensible il fallait que elle soit
sensible pour moi aussi alors à naître
Viviane
croise la grande Histoire peut-on garder
la distance nécessaire en tant
qu'historienne peut-on travailler sur
des archives qui touchent à l'intime et
comment préserver la mémoire de la Shoah
alors que les générations se succèdent
sommes-nous prêts à entrer dans l'air du
non témoin à vous la parole
[Musique]
beaucoup de questions à vous poser ce
soir un être viviorka bonsoir et merci
d'être là pour ces tombeaux au pluriel
aux éditions du Seuil cette auto
autobiographie de ma famille vous dites
je voilà est-ce que c'est la
boutiquement au fond de tous les livres
précédents est-ce qu'il fallait être
historienne pour réussir à prendre la
plume et raconter les viviorka raconter
les fêtes man raconter les perles man
entre autres alors non quelqu'un de non
historien aurait pu faire un faire un
récit mais ça n'aurait pas été le même
en fait je pense que ce récit
mêle à la fois ma propre sensibilité ma
propre sensibilité à cette histoire et
ce qui a fait mon métier c'est à dire le
fait de chercher toujours la vérité et
le fait de chercher toujours
attitude notamment l'exactitude des mots
donc je pense que c'est cette aliage qui
fait ce livre qui est un récit
littéraire et qui l'écriture à une place
très importante
très importante parce que mon objectif
n'était pas de
reparler de la Shoah qui n'occupe pas
une place si importante mais mon
objectif c'était aussi de raconter ses
vies ces vides immigrés puisque des deux
côtés de ma famille ce sont des immigrés
juifs de Pologne et de raconter ce qui a
été leur immigration leur vie leurs
engagements politiques leur joie c'est
un récit qui n'est pas sinistre le
déclic le déclic c'est Berthe alors
racontez-nous parce que vous aviez
commencé un peu arrêter
bon d'abord j'avais réfléchi quand je
suis rentré de Chine c'est mon second
récit parce que j'ai publié mes années
chinoises qui étaient le récit de
la période où j'étais professeurs
l'Institut des langues étrangères de la
province du quantum dans la Chine de la
fin de la Révolution d'une grande
désillusion aussi et qui a été une
grande désillusion donc j'avais commencé
à rassembler plein de matériaux j'avais
interrogé très longuement mon père mon
oncle mais un des qui a été
effectivement le décès de Berthe côté
père elmale racontez-moi un peu Berthe
parce que c'est formidable ce premier
chapitre et
Berthe elle décède en 2012 et
elle décède après sa fille et son mari
et avec mon cousin Marc marcelman nous
vidons son appartement qui était un
appartement loué il fallait le vider et
à ce moment là il y a quelque chose qui
m'a étreint
c'est que elle ne laisserait aucune
trace elle a pas écrit elle a pas peint
elle a pas de descendants elle a pas de
propriété rien vous dites c'est une
branche morte c'est une branche morte et
je me dis voilà si nous ces neveux ne
nous souvenons encore vraiment d'elle
d'autant que moi j'ai habité dans le
même immeuble pendant une vingtaine
d'années
qu'est-ce qu'il en sera après et j'ai
commencé à écrire
un tombeau parce que c'est là que le
titre de trop beau m'est venu
en sous-titre ce qui est le adieu Berthe
c'était aussi un clin d'oeil au film de
Denis
en même temps que son décès et dont on a
aussi dit à Dieu à Berthe et
puis j'ai pas continué mais c'est ce
premier texte que j'ai repris et qui
fait l'introduction de ces tombeaux
alors il y a vol vivre il y a énormément
de personnages donc lui c'est le
journaliste le grand-père lui c'est le
grand-père intellectuel
et puis il y a côté chasse qui elle les
tailleurs tes œufs elles sont très
différentes ces deux branches familiales
alors ces deux branches quand on y
réfléchit elles sont sociologiquement
quasiment identiques ils émigrent de
Pologne dans la même période il parle il
dit c'est leur langue c'est pas un choix
identitaire c'est vraiment leur langue
il ils sont de sensibilité à gauche
plutôt
existe socialiste du côté de la famille
paternelle plutôt proche et communiste
de la famille maternelle et pourtant
tous les séparent
rassequel Perelman mon grand-père le
seul que j'ai connu parce que c'est le
seul qui a survécu à la guerre à la
Shoah lui on pourrait dire qu'il est
déportés les autres ont été déportés ma
grand-mère maternelle noyée quand les
Allemands tirés sur la barque
[Musique]
et les autres déportés et donc on
pourrait dire qu'il est typique mais
quand on creuse une famille typique on
trouve que c'est pas si typique que ça
parce que Bert est la fille aînée est un
personnage singulier et le fils
Roger Perelman qui lui a été déporté
mais revient de déportation aussi un
destin très très particulier ce qui est
intéressant
pour moi la grande figure ça a été vole
ce viviorca écrivain journaliste le fil
rouge et c'est le fil rouge et c'est
aussi de lui que j'ai appris que et bien
on pouvait disparaître
et que l'écrit restait la trace et donc
cette trace que vous vouliez aussi et
c'est tout ce qui n'ont pas c'est
peut-être aussi ma propre trace que je
laisse en faisant des livres oui parce
que vous vous racontez d'une certaine
manière à travers les vôtres un peu mais
oui vous faites écrivain c'est clair
dans ce livre autant historienne vous
avez travaillé sur des archives
sensibles ce qui est pas forcément
évident des carnets des vêtements des
objets des mémoires certains en ont
écrit des articles et puis vous êtes
allés chercher en historienne aussi
d'autres archives comment ça s'est passé
ce travail là alors il y avait ce que
j'avais rassemblé un peu au fil du temps
et puis ensuite j'ai été très
systématique et c'est là que mon métier
m'a servi donc je suis allé regarder
les dossiers de la police des des
étrangers de la préfecture de police qui
miraculeusement ont été conservés
mon père et mon oncle sont passés en
Suisse clandestinement en octobre 42 je
suis allé à Berne aux archives fédéral
regardez leur dossiers
j'ai passé le même code qui n'était pas
bon pour moi c'était un mini exploit
sportif mais j'ai passé le col de cou
comme eux même l'avait passé en octobre
et puis je suis à Nice dans les archives
départementales puisque ils ont passé
tout le début de l'occupation à Nice
donc là effectivement j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de choses dans les archives et
ça nourrit mon Mauricie je voulais vous
demander cet exergue que vous avez mis
de Richard Ford sur un extrait de ma
mère je le lis c'est une des
particularités de la vie avec nos
parents que l'on oublie souvent et qui
passe donc inaperçus nos parents nous
relient aussi isolés que nous soyons
dans notre existence à une chose que
nous ne sommes pas mais qui mais qu'ils
sont il y a là une coupure peut-être
même un mystère si bien que même
ensemble nous sommes seuls
oui j'ai trouvé que cette phrase était
extraordinaire parce que elle marque à
la fois le fait que nous ne sommes pas
nos parents et que malgré tout la vie de
nos parents et nos grands-parents qui
sont beaucoup de mes parents aussi nous
et aux pattes mais que malgré tout nous
sommes liés et bon pour souvent des
questions sur la transmission je pense
que dans les familles le plus important
c'est moins la transmission que le lien
c'est-à-dire de donner le sentiment
d'être relié surtout
quand comme dans nos familles il y a eu
deux ruptures majeures la première étant
celle de l'immigration la seconde étant
celle de la Shoah la Shoah parachevant
en fait celle de l'immigration puisque
ce monde qui qu'ils avaient laissé
derrière eux à totalement disparu alors
somme nous prêts à entrer dans l'air
d'une non témoin pour répondre à la
question qui vous était adressée dans le
sud pour terminer très rapidement on est
en plein dans l'air du témoin on a vu le
procès du Bataclan et on a vu la place
qui a été donnée au témoin dans ce
process ce même procès aurait eu lieu il
y a 30 ans on n'aurait pas entendu comme
ça les victimes donc on est en plein
l'air du témoin
et des survivants de la Shoah on est
prêt c'est-à-dire que le temps a passé
les les enfants d'aujourd'hui ont des
grands-parents nés après la guerre
la sensibilité n'est plus la même il y a
plus on va aller vers au moment où il y
aura plus de mémoire vive
vous le redoutez
non je le redoute pas enfin je redoute
ce qui se passe partout dans le monde
mais je redoute pas ce moment c'est le
c'est la c'est la loi de l'histoire j'ai
rencontré il y a peu un des petits
enfants de Simone Veil qui me disaient
ben moi j'ai vu le numéro de ma
grand-mère mais mes enfants n'ont pas vu
le numéro le tatouage de ma grand-mère
et je trouve que ça résume très bien les
choses c'est que cela ceux qui ont
survécu ou qui ont vécu pendant la
période de la guerre bientôt ne seront
plus du tout parmi nous le temps à
passer mais le temps a passé après 14-18
et pas le temps et la vie et là ce qui
s'est passé depuis 30 ans en matière de
recueil de témoignages de publications
d'oeuvre de travail des historiens fait
qu'on peut dire que c'est vraiment
inscrit dans l'histoire
tombeau au pluriel autobiographie de ma
famille ça se lit comme un grand récit
littéraire mais c'est aussi de
l'histoire et merci pour ce livre c'est
au seuil c'est moi vous restez avec moi
Nadia yorka on va accueillir à présent
nos affranchis pour leur partie prix ils
vont vous faire réagir Marco pommier
d'abord qui a récolté les pronostics des
députés sur la demi-finale France Maroc
de demain et puis toutes les polémiques
un peu stériles qui entourent ce match
le parti pris de Vincent huge sur la
conférence de Paris pour l'Ukraine ne
pas oublier qu'avant la pré guerre il y
a la guerre et puis le regard de la
féministe lait à chamboncelle sur le
bilan de la parité en politique un
rapport était remis hier à la première
ministre nos affranchis les voici
bonsoir à tous les trois on va commencer
avec vous Marco ce soir on parle
football puisque demain la France
affronte le Maroc en demi-finale un
match qui s'est joué enfin qui se joue
un peu aussi dans l'hémicycle oui Myriam
c'est ça une demi-finale qui se joue sur
le terrain politique comment pourrait-il
en être autrement
une affiche historique sur le plan
sportif et symbolique les deux pays sont
liés par une histoire d'immigration et
de colonisation et à l'image de notre
pays est bien l'Assemblée nationale le
compte quelques députés français
d'origine marocaine un drapeau français
sur une joue un drapeau marocain sur
l'autre alors pour qui leur cœur balance
on leur a posé la question
pour qui mon coeur balance France Maroc
comme on peut on choisir entre son père
et sa mère les deux mon cœur balance
parce que ça va être un match de foot
exceptionnel historique France baroque
c'est avant tout un match de foot c'est
du sport les deux équipes auront envie
de gagner alors moi je m'excuse
vis-à-vis de ma maman qui est pour le
Maroc moi c'est allez les bleus
allez les bleus vous l'avez compris
Myriam elle s'est députée et bien il
défendent surtout l'amitié
franco-marocaine l'esprit festif du
football d'autant que cette affiche
sportive n'échappe pas aux polémique ce
week-end le rassemblement national
notamment pointé du doigt les
débordements sur les Champs-Élysées
après la victoire du Maroc face au
Portugal ici à l'assemblée des députés
eren se disent même choquer par l'idée
que les Francos marocains puissent
manifester leur joie dans la rue après
la victoire écoutez Julien Odoul
non ce qui me choque c'est les
manifestations
communautaristes que l'on a pu voir dans
nos rues avec des gens qui sont nés en
France à qui la France a tout donné qui
sont à l'école de la République qui ont
été formés qui ont bénéficié je dirais
de la solidarité nationale française et
qui manifeste une appartenance un autre
pays c'est ça qui me qui me choque après
que l'on soit d'origine étrangère et
qu'on est une tendresse particulière
devant sa télé pour l'équipe de son père
ou de ses grands-parents ça me choque
pas bon Myriam malgré les polémiques
c'est plutôt l'effervescence qui règne à
l'Assemblée à la veille d'un match qui
s'annonce passionnant et passionné nos
députés qui se sont même risqués au jeu
du pronostic écoutez
France Maroc un pronostic bah écoutez
forcément moi je suis un peu chauvin
donc ça sera la France en premier mais
j'ai pas envie d'humilier qui que ce
soit donc un deux un me semblerait un
bon très beau résultat je suis pas
Madame Soleil mais
trois ans très bien je pense quand même
qu'on va mettre au mois d'août 3 buts
d'avant
Charles au moins deux au moins deux de 0
du coup de zéro ou trois et on va tous
regarder le match parce que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
pris une bonne initiative c'est-à-dire
de suspendre nos travaux pendant le
match voilà et c'est ça la bonne
nouvelle c'est ça la bonne nouvelle pour
les députés la décision elle a été prise
ce matin demain les travaux
parlementaires reprendront à 22h au lieu
de 21h30 habituellement elle est députée
pourront donc regarder le match jusqu'au
coup de sifflet final sauf si on va
jusqu'au tir au but dans ce cas là le
suspense et bien il se prolongera bien
au-delà de 22h bref le coq français
va-t-il faire qu'une bouchée des Lions
de l'Atlas c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
l'équipe du Maroc réponse demain soir à
20h vous avez un pronostic Myriam allez
2-0 2-0 analyverka vous allez regarder
le match non bonjour
pas plus cette année
vous êtes pas trop au foot ok bah il en
faut aussi alors ça va vous intéresser à
Nadia j'en suis sûr Vincent nous parle
ce soir de cette grande conférence pour
l'Ukraine qui s'est tenue à Paris
soutient de la France de tous les alliés
de l'Ukraine initiative évidemment
louable nécessaire mais ambivalente à
vos yeux oui deux conférences pour le
prix d'une première acte ce matin sous
le noble étendard de la solidarité
active avec le peuple ukrainien du
concret d'ailleurs sur cinq fronts
vitaux l'énergie l'eau l'alimentation la
santé les transports il s'agit de faire
échec dans l'urgence à la stratégie
apocalyptique de Moscou qui faute de
triompher par les armes ces Chine a
brisé le moral du voisin agressé au prix
de l'anéantissement de ces
infrastructures civiles histoire de le
plonger dans une nuit sans fin
terrifiante et glacée second acte cet
après-midi à Bercy sur le registre
bilatéral cette fois près de 700
entreprises française du cador du CAC 40
à la start-up numérique invité à se
lancer dans l'aventure de la
reconstruction d'un pays meurtri deux
chiffres suffisent à mesurer l'ampleur
du chantier un produit intérieur brut
amputé de 40% du mois et le quart de la
population sous le seuil de pauvreté tôt
décuplé depuis février donc difficile de
contester cette opération estimable
alors anticiper bien sûr pensez
l'après-guerre évidemment le hic et on
me pardonnera une telle la palissade
c'est qu'avant la prière il y a la
guerre jamais le déluge de missile russe
n'a été si dévastateur quand ce début
d'hiver c'est d'abord à cette œuvre de
mort qu'il faut mettre fin à quoi bon
relever un pont un hôpital une école une
centrale électrique qui peuvent être
réduits demain à l'état de ruine fumante
chaque chose en son temps le temps
parlons-en le temps et le en même temps
si cher à Emmanuel Macron un concept
stimulant mais dont l'entreprise soviéto
colon de Vladimir Poutine révèle toute
la vanité il ne peut y avoir de
victoires de l'Ukraine sans défaite du
Kremlin or le Jupiter Elyséen semble
ruschini à se rendre à cette évidence et
du moins ce que suggère plusieurs de ses
embardes rhétoriques lesquels ont au
mieux des concertés au pire atterrés
Kiev et nos alliés baltes ouest
européens
d'abord bien sûr à la fameuse injonction
selon laquelle il ne faut pas humilier
la Russie ensuite à la nécessité à
léguer voilà peu d'offrir à Moscou des
garanties de sécurité Poutine avant
Macron craint que l'OTAN Vienne jusqu'à
ses portes pauvres Vlady comme si ce
n'était pas lui qui avait décidé de
pousser vers l'ouest le seuil de son
empire tout se passe au fond comme si le
locataire de l'Elysée ne dissipait à
malentendu que pour oser une ambiguïté
il a parlé juste ce mardi rendant lui
cette justice pourvue que ça dure dans
une analyse incisive publiée hier le
monde rappelle le raccourci hasardé en
août 2019 au Fort de Brégançon théâtre
ta tête Macron Poutine que dit alors le
maître des lieux et bien ceci la Russie
est une grande puissance des lumières
elle a sa place dans l'Europe des
valeurs à laquelle nous croyons voilà ce
qu'il advient quand on prête l'oreille
au mentor de ces jeunes années
Jean-Pierre Chevènement aussi implacable
en procure de l'atlantisme que
bienveillant à l'heure de revêtir la
robe d'avocats de Moscou voilà ce qui
guette celui que séduit le réalisme d'un
Hubert Védrine trop épris de lucidité
pour ne pas céder parfois au sinistre
mais il ne manque au logiciel d'Emmanuel
Macron ce cadra transgressif ni le brio
ni la virtualité intellectuelle il lui
manque sans doute la science du timing
est plus gênant le sens tragique de
l'histoire merci beaucoup voilà un parti
pris un nouveau Vincent Hugo année
divorca je serai assez d'accord avec
avec ce parti pris et effectivement une
guerre c'est une guerre il y a un
vainqueur il y a un vaincu et bon ça se
terminera effectivement probablement par
une négociation mais on ne peut pas
souhaiter une sorte parce qu'on parlait
de football on va pas souhaiter un match
nul entre l'Ukraine et l'Ukraine et la
Russie parce qu'on a un agresseur
un pays qui appartient malgré quelques
défauts
au camp démocratiques et pour moi les
choses sont assez
de mener la guerre qu'on a vu en Syrie
enfin c'est pas non plus une nouveauté
totale la façon dont dans les Russes
font la guerre et la font
au mépris de tout le droit de la guerre
qui a été construit pendant pendant un
siècle et demi depuis la fin du 19e
siècle en
Ukraine à l'historienne que vous êtes et
aux historiens qui vont devoir sortir
les archives très vite
il y a un sens de l'histoire
une connaissance de l'histoire trop
limitée chez notre président
Léa pour terminer vous vous y revenir
sur la question de la parité en
politique il y a un rapport qui a été
remis je le disais à Elisabeth borne
hier par le Haut Conseil à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes que
dit-il effectivement ce rapport
préconise en fait d'entamer un acte 2 de
la parité afin de proposer des solutions
concrètes pour véritablement renforcer
la place des femmes en politique en
France côté bilan il semble quand même
important de rappeler quelques chiffres
sur lesquels revient aussi le rapport on
compte 37% de femmes à l'Assemblée
nationale les géroccules par rapport à
la précédente législature et 35% de
femmes au Sénat ça c'est pas la parité
et ça c'est pas tout à fait la parité
effectivement néanmoins elle est
respectée au sein du gouvernement mais
les femmes sont quand même plus
nombreuses à occuper des postes de
secrétaire d'État neuf femmes contre un
seul homme et moins nombreuses à diriger
bien sûr des ministères et galliens
seulement une femme contre quatre hommes
alors ça c'est les membres du
gouvernement est-ce qu'on connaît la
parité au sein des cabinets ministériels
et bien non c'est encore pire parce que
là on apprend dans ce rapport que
seulement 7 cabinets sur sept sont
parfaitement paritaires et que seulement
8 cabinets sont dirigés par les femmes
mais ce que nous rappelle aussi ce
rapport et c'est important de le
souligner de manière d'ailleurs très
très circonstanciée c'est que le monde
politique a été conçu par les hommes et
pour les hommes et que ils règnent
encore malheureusement un sexisme très
important et aussi des violences
sexuelles et sexistes qui est difficile
d'enrayer il est aussi important de
souligner que la parité en politique
au-delà de la nécessité démocratique
qu'elle peut représenter peut réellement
permettre en fait d'améliorer la
décision publique on y apportant des
expériences des regards mais aussi des
pratiques différentes donc elle n'est
pas acquise on le voit notamment dans
les cabinets ministériels qu'est-ce que
on peut faire que
dans les assemblées de de la Quatrième
République et du début de la cinquième
c'était
un petit pourcentage que des hommes ce
qu'on appelle le discours de Simone Veil
au moment de la loi sur l'avortement
elle disait je parle devant une
assemblée d'hommes et elle parlait
effectivement devant une assemblée
d'hommes bon allez quelques progrès mais
peut mieux faire merci merci Léa merci
Vincent Marco merci à vous lisez ton
beau autobiographie de ma famille au
seuil signé Annette viviorka merci à
vous c'est la fin de cette émission très
belle soirée documentaire sur LCP à
demain même lui-même
[Musique]